school chess he was much quicker than he
usually is so i think it's something
he's been working on for sure
interesting
vladislava tell me if they are ready the
games should be starting any second now
we do see a few games in the bottom of
the screen have already started we're
going to pay attention to all of the
games going on you guys and update you
of course on results and we're gonna
jump into as many games as we can but we
will always follow one game at a time
so now we're gonna follow this game
until it's finished
and if we have time we're going to jump
into another game or we're going to wait
until the next round what do you think
is this going to be a long game and here
we go it's finally starting my
prediction
yeah a very rare first move from magnus
carlton he's pushed his g pawn forward
just one square getting really ready not
even the b pawn it's not even the b pawn
which we saw a lot last season
popularized by adiban of course the
indian grandmaster magnus he's pushed
upon but it's the same idea just on the
other side of the board the white light
squared bishop is just going to slide
across one square to a long diagonal but
this has got to be unexpected for
artemiev artemiv actually is a king of
rare openings himself
but magnus rarely employs something like
this yeah i'm pretty sure that i've seen
artemia play this type of opening with
the white pieces himself so
using his own poison against him maybe
magnus carlsen he teased us there
waiting just letting us kind of hang on
the first move and it's a big surprise
already i'm wondering whether artemis
knows the game has started or whether
he's just in such big shock
of magnus's first move
okay artemis does reply brings his night
out very standard very natural stuff
he's keeping his central pawns flexible
and i expect to see magnus now develop
that white light squared bishop there we
go it sits on the g2 square where it has
great range along a very potent diagonal
yeah and now i'm curious to see what
kind of strategy i'll tell me if we'll
we'll adapt because here
here is just answer it he's put his pawn
on light squares so well i expect all
the pawns to go on the light squares
from now on from artemyev and there we
go one thing that we expected to see
throughout the tour was magnus eating
noodles he's at it again already in the
first game of the champions chester yeah
served him well last year well mostly
well yeah oh it was a little bit up and
down actually yeah
the noodle gambit and now we see both
players revert to more standard um more
normal types of development white has
got the king castled now challenging the
black central pawn before black's king
is safe and it's a temporary gambit that
can take that pawn but the black pawn
would not last very long maybe black
wants to maintain more influence in the
center by just backing up his central
pawn with another pawn
critical moment here actually because
artemiev has a range of options he can
actually support that pawn in the middle
of the board by pushing up his c pawn
one square forward just reinforcing that
light square strategy he can also just
castle and just say hey i'm going to
give you the santa but what i'm going to
do is once you occupy the center i'm
going to attack it with pieces um he can
even this is a really risky choice push
that pawn one square forward and that
would be the maximalist approach the
black central pawn yes gaining as much
space as possible he actually captures
uh we see a pawn trade i was about to
say i had a serious case of deja vu
because just last week i played a
friendly game against magnus and it was
in the exact position as black i brought
my knight out but uh here artemis just
chooses to release the tension
uh by exchanging a set of pawns and i
mentioned black has gone a pawn up but
it's not going to last long white's
knight now sitting on the edge of the
board not on a great square but next
move magnus is going to re-centralize
that knight and recapture the black pawn
restoring material balance it's a bit
cagey so far
it's still very tense very early days
but it shows magnus wants to keep as
many pieces on the board as possible
porn trades are fine but peace play will
be the
battleground later on
yeah there's one big danger here for
black in this type of position and
that's if you allow white to simply
recapture the pawn with a knight and
then establish a stronghold in the
center it could be a case of
whose light square bishop is better you
know white's light square bishop is on
the perfect long diagonal and the black
doesn't find a role for his own bishop
well then
white is just comfortably better and
it's just gonna be very pleasant days
happy days for white yeah it doesn't
sound like much but also once that black
pawn disappears white will have two
central pawns on the two central files
black only has one so white is kind of
exchanged off a flank pawn it's not
quite a flank pawn but a pawn at the
side of the board for a central pawn and
that's a tiny little gain it's at least
a moral victory it is from magnus and
actually he employed similar setups in
the world championship match against
janaponnichi so
yeah magnus uh not his usual strategy
maybe but showing that over the last
year or so he has evolved his game and
it doesn't look like tommy's too
comfortable if you see on the camera
already his head in his hands already
spending a couple of minutes and it's
only move six
how how rare is this opening choice by
magnus
from him it's rare i've seen as you
might mention i've seen artemis employ
this type of thing from the white side
quite regularly i employ it from the
white side
very often but it's not normally
magnus's style he's more classical he
likes to occupy the center with pawns
slowly maneuver bring his pieces out
and uh yeah this one
yeah it's definitely gonna heat up later
but i'll tell you i'm getting worried
already we talked about the clock
situation and yeah he's still got 12 and
a bit minutes left but
yeah things are going to heat up he
needs that time for later exactly and uh
he's taking the time to consider what
type of
position he should be going for so now
he castles the king it's a very natural
move and after knight takes pawn it's
here where he has to make that decision
and he's done it he's actually pushed
his pawn forward see pawn two squares
that's actually not the main line the
main line was actually developing the
knight
on the left side
yeah so uh will this move cause magnus
to think he's just still tucking away
into his noodles um yeah ivanka you're
right this one for me is a bit odd as
well um black trying to get some
influence over the center so it looks
logical this pawn push but then again if
you look at the black pieces on that
left side they're undeveloped they're
not ready for the center to open up so i
wouldn't be surprised if magnus pushes
his central pawn forward the white d
pawn two squares tries to explode open
the position before black is ready
so yeah maybe surprised by a slightly
rare move magnus will spend a couple of
minutes
i'm getting a bit jealous of that food
now
magnus after just
uh kind of getting his bearings he will
probably push a pawn forward in the
center yeah uh one one square two
squares i think two what do you think
your anchor
one square
okay he doesn't push the central pawn he
pushes the beep on so
something that you mentioned kaya the b3
opening just slightly delayed
he saved it from move eight well he's
keeping on the flanks today the world
champion so far yeah and he's consistent
he's trying to play a bit of symmetry
with his bishops both bishops going out
to their longest possible diagonals
they're going to try and create that
crisscross effect later on yeah like
just bringing a knight out there and
magnus will for sure bring out his dark
square bishop
there aren't too many games in the
database actually but there is one
notable game between ding loren and uh
neil shanklin that was a really quick uh
game that was played with maybe three
minutes on the clock so
okay you shouldn't really take this game
so seriously but okay there white
actually won
okay
that's important to know we love our
stats here right so yes
the fact that white has a good score or
at least among top level players from
this position means
it might be quite promising also we
should mention it's a new season but we
still have the evaluation bar just above
the players cameras and right now the
evaluation bar says white has a 0.9
advantage so if it goes over to the left
it means white's doing well if it goes
over to the right black is doing better
so
we'll keep an eye on that we won't trust
it yet it's still early days but uh yeah
i do quite like white's position i love
the two white bishops very flexibly
placed
and the computer seems to approve of
what magnus is doing as well
and uh just through kind of some unusual
move orders we're now transposed into
something where more games have been
played and here
nearly every single game has kind of
gone the moment is now
push the queen spawn two squares open
and explode open the position so things
are going to heat up now okay so now is
the moment ivanka and uh just to show
this idea white can already as you
mentioned push put this pawn forward
exploding things open this would lead to
potentially a lot of trades maybe even
an end game so that might cause magnus
to hesitate against an endgame maestro
like artemiev but after white pushes in
the center black will recapture we'll
see another trade the knights will come
off the board maybe even the queens will
come off here and this position it looks
pretty balanced but then again we've
talked about the bishops a lot and this
bishop is fantastic this bishop as well
hitting one of the black pawns and these
two black pawns are just very loose
they're very vulnerable and
it looks roughly balanced apart from the
bishops and the quality of those pieces
and that would be why white has a small
advantage i wouldn't be surprised to see
magnus play this in the current position
pushing this pawn forward trying to
trade pieces but if he wants a quieter
longer maneuvering game then maybe we'll
see him just push his pawn one square
just kind of inch forward keep all the
pieces on the board it's a matter of
taste let's see what type of mood the
world champion's in he is definitely
thinking now magnus carlsen and you did
mention david this is a season that's
going to be very much influenced by by
stats we're going to talk about stats a
lot and we do have that tour rating
magnus starting at
what is it 28.60 i think is it yeah 2860
something yeah 2865. yeah i mean that's
a pretty
gigantic rating yeah stratospheric but
we know he's going for 2 900 in
classical chess
is is the odds are that he's going to
reach that faster in in the online tour
rating quite possibly um so meanwhile
magnus just pushed his pawn for one
square which means he wants maximum
attention um actually this season on the
tour um
we are using a multiplication factor of
20 and in classical chess over the board
chess the multiplication factor is only
10. okay so that means players can
actually double the amount that they
would gain compared to classical chess
if they perform well but they would also
double the amount they lose
if they're not doing so well so um that
we'll see big fluctuations in rating
magnus he
loves his numbers he loves his stats i
think maybe more than anyone in the
chess world and if he gets 2 900 i'm
sure in the tour i'm sure we'll see him
brag about it it's definitely going to
be on his mind could we even at some
point maybe next year start talking
about
3 000. that is like the magical yeah no
one's ever gotten close to that people
have done performances performances over
three thousand but it's rare it's uh no
one's come close yeah not in classical
over-the-board chess at least one thing
i should mention though is magnus plays
a lot online he plays a lot of blitz in
his free time for example on chess 24
his rating there is over 3000 and there
it's slightly inflated because there's
so many players playing all the time
it's easy to get games but
it's not impossible if he goes on a
streak like he did last season in the
tour 2900 might just be the first step
wow
it's going to be fun to follow we did
have a few uh moves in the game yeah so
just very solid moves we didn't go for
your idea ivanka and the move you said
had been played several times before
exploding open the center magnus just
taking a slower approach now he's just
pushed a pawn forward one square and
pushed his queen forward one square and
connected the two white rooks
rooks usually are happier when they're
connected it just means they have more
access to whichever files whichever
lines open up later um so yeah just very
logical play from both sides not
committing anything yet
and i think magnus for sure he's got a
strategy in mind he's going to try and
play against artemis clock a bit later
on what is he doing okay meanwhile
magnus just swiveling on that chair
oh i've got a temptation to do the same
now but uh we see the secret lab chair
as well i think all of the players are
going to be using that throughout the
tour
it's a very comfortable chair yeah super
comfortable perfect for gaming perfect
for esports
and online chess so yeah magnus just
distracted there for a second i don't
think there was anything suspicious
going on there i think he was just
getting a bottle of water or something
and uh yeah artemis needs to speed up
he's a couple of minutes behind on the
clock but it's still early days there's
a lot of action left in this game later
and
that's the one criticism i've had of him
and that we've all had of him
later in the game he's on the last few
seconds and
gives us nervy moments and gives him
nervy moments too
and meanwhile one thing i should mention
as well we talked about the evaluation
bars look at that game between esipenko
and mama jarov i think within two or
three minutes of that game starting the
bar was all the way
all away to essepenko's side
could be a great start from the
youngster
yeah and uh
okay so um our tamiya has actually moved
his queen forward connecting the two
rooks together means the two rooks are
indestructible i like that kind of idea
but um yeah i know black's next plan is
to move his other rook next to the king
move it to the square behind the queen
and just continue putting pressure on
the center and say to white
you know you're quite far back with your
pawns you're not going to advance them
forward
so it's kind of almost like
baseline tennis or in a way both sides
are kind of making their shots from the
back yeah neither side can really
spring forward approach the net because
then i think bad things might happen
they might not be ready for it the
opponent might have a shot over them and
yeah both sides actually if you notice
they're in their own territory right now
white just kind of huddling on his first
three four ranks and black doing the
same
uh personally i slightly prefer black's
position actually now that white hasn't
broken forward in the center because
black's pawn structure if you look on
the left hand side the three pawns there
they support each other very well they
kind of clamp down on any pawn pushes
from white
which means it's actually harder for
white to find a plan as vancouver
mentioned black's next move is simple
it's straightforward just bringing a
rook to the center
what's white doing in the meantime
that's why magnus is thinking yeah and
is there also a positional threat of uh
the black queen and the bishop being
aligned together on the same diagonal
and the black bishop coming and trying
to make a trade with its counterparts
just to kind of soften those light
squares around the white king yep that's
a really good point and actually this is
something that we see a lot happen
especially maybe a club level at uh
beginner level these two pieces they do
line up on the same diagonal as ivanka
mentioned if white just takes a timeout
just improves the rook a very natural
move the bishop might spring forward and
this is one thing for all the viewers at
home i recommend not to do never ever
take the bishop on black's terms or on
your opponent's terms because this would
allow firstly an uh bad trade white's
bishop there is a key piece but secondly
it would allow the black queen into the
position suddenly black has ideas next
move of bringing the knight forward
maybe later on if the stars line trying
to checkmate the white king the white
king does not feel safe now because the
black queen is so near and uh yep
definitely one of the
concepts that artemiev is lining up
potentially he wants to bring his bishop
and trade off white's best piece
best minor piece at least so if this
does happen for example i would expect
to see magnus run away from the trade
maybe just retreat his bishop or if he
wants to allow the trade just for
example making a move at least let it
happen on your own terms let black spend
the time trading off the pieces and now
the white king is pretty safe because
the black queen can't enter the position
so this is actually a very very common
pattern and just one to remember don't
allow your opponent's queen near your
king it will end in disaster
absolutely
that's one of the fundamental rules that
i live by it's like don't let your
opponent's pieces into your side of the
ball yeah you got to be possessive and
if they do by chance enter then you're
like okay well i will get rid of the the
most aggressive one and the black queen
she's a fantastic attacker so yeah i
actually fell foul of this rule in a
game i had against fabiana caruana in a
classical chess yeah and i let the queen
the white queen in this case live on on
a square on the h6 square
and he was saying to me after the game
why did you do that why did you not kick
her away and i'm like
yeah because i was working outside
forcing lines and he goes no no just
kick the queen back and then continue
the game so a valuable lesson there yeah
happens to all of us at some point
well
but this bishop the magnus has
it doesn't look like a good bit will he
lose that bishop anyways it looks kind
of trapped basically i guess one thing
magnus is considering right now is to
move away the white knight from the king
side uh just move it out the way and
then white's light squared bishop has a
whole diagonal to look at it will
control a lot of squares so it might not
look great right now but firstly it's a
protective piece it guards the white
king and secondly it will have its eye
line on a fantastic diagonal once the
white knight on f3 moves out the way
once that kingside white knight just
shifts so maybe magnus is actually going
to move that knight now i wouldn't be
surprised by that the white knight for
example could jump into the center of
the board and actually hit the black
queen but that would result in some
trades so magnus just deciding whether
now is the moment to leap forward or
whether to just again maintain the
status quo allow that trade to happen
maybe but on his own terms and
meanwhile this is the air things masters
and now we can see the air quality in
magnus carlson's home office
from where he's playing and
it looks very warm in there 26 degrees
just uh the way he likes it that's the
way he likes it
not
yeah
so
but okay when it comes to the co2 levels
that's uh spot on yeah and the particle
matter no pollution in that room
uh looking good
in those stakes so that's one thing
we'll keep on
checking out throughout this tournament
the air quality stats um i recently
played uh some friendly games with our
friend asgild and uh yeah we were
testing the air quality and it really
does make a difference actually we'll
see that maybe the longer the day goes
on
yeah so okay meanwhile both sides have
just brought their rooks to the center
that idea that your manga mentioned of
bringing the bishop forward keep that
one in mind for later
uh okay magnus has jumped forward with
the knight so he's actually combined all
the ideas we mentioned and now we have
seen a trade of one set of nights
and the black queen is under attack she
has to move she has to find herself on a
safe square
but guys we have the first result of uh
the champions chess tour 2022 wow
esipenko the young russian player he's
won again impressive stuff the 19 year
old in his very first game in his very
first tournament in his very first
season of the multiple champions chess
store a win taking the lead already
andre esipenko and a bad start for
shakira and mamadiara but
if there's one thing we know about mom
nyarov it is that he can make a comeback
and he can definitely win some games as
well but what a start for ezipenko
yeah i just took a peek over at that
game it looks like esopenko tricked his
opponent tricked major of in the opening
he won a piece as early as move 11. wow
and actually that game ended pretty much
in checkmate or it was about to be
checkmate and it was that exact pattern
that we just pointed out ivanka of one
of the queens pouncing near the
opponent's king and just yep combining
with the rest of her pieces uh trapping
the opponent's king so yeah it's an
important pattern to keep an eye on yeah
well i said go and he's gonna face
magnus in uh round three today yeah no
he's on fire yeah it's an ideal
him
start
know to win so effortlessly a little bit
unfortunate for mama jaroff but like you
say his powers of recovery are quite
substantial and he's used to this kind
of sea saw
of of results yeah he's used to winning
and then losing yeah right
and uh very few draws that's my majority
of style yeah we love him so definitely
that's why he has his place in our
hearts and on the tour yep and uh well
going back to this position there's a
big question for artemiev to answer
which is like where is he going to put
the queen
um
i would be reluctant to move it in the
eye line of the white rook but then
again i kind of don't really want to
advance her
forward yeah so the black queen under
attack from this night she has to move
as you mentioned shifting her across one
square she won't feel entirely
comfortable on this line for example
white can now push forward with a pawn
maybe one of these two pawns and try and
break through towards her towards that
black queen
so i don't think we'll see her land on
that square also one thing to mention
this white knight combined with this
white bishop now they're the they're the
dream duo they team up perfectly because
the white knight can actually pounce and
jump into the position attacking the
black rook this would lead to some
really bad consequences for black
because this knight as well protected by
its bishop we talked about that bishop
being a key piece
therefore i think we'll see the queen
find a different square
if artemis is feeling a bit scared a bit
passive then he would just retreat her
to a safe square such as this one i
don't really like this to be honest
because queens want to be on active
lines active diagonals i think the most
likely move that we will see after some
thought from artemis is the queen to
this square a slightly more active
square she's pretty safe here for now
she looks like she might get attacked at
some point maybe by a pawn but this
wouldn't be possible at the moment
because the black queen could maybe just
capture on this square she could even
just retreat and i don't think magnus
really wants to loosen up his queen side
pawns yet they will just be targets for
example from black's bishop so this one
looks like the most active square in the
position but we'll learn a lot about
what atomic is thinking here depending
on which square he chooses for the queen
if she steps back he's feeling a bit
scared if he steps forward he maybe
likes his position and wants to be more
ambitious let's go back to the players
it's a big moment as ivanka said and
artemis has spent quite a lot of time
yeah he needs to move that queen he does
need to move that queen and i just
peeked at the computer's evaluations and
the computer says basically
there are three queen queen retreats
that are fine so he can move the queen
one square forward he can move it it
really likes your move of moving it to
two squares along the diagonal even
backwards is okay but what he must not
do absolutely must not do is put the
queen in the eye line of the rook
because of the move that you highlighted
there white would just be better
okay so four safe squares but three of
them are fine one of them is bad one of
them is bad yeah one of them will be
drinking it would be like drinking
poison yeah that's one of the toughest
things in chess when you know you have
three or four options actually they're
forced to move so you have only four
moves to consider how do you compare
them how do you choose between the four
viable options maybe three of them have
roughly the same value they won't alter
the evaluation of the position
uh at some point especially in rapid
chess especially in online chess you
just got to say okay this is fine that's
good enough i'll play this move and then
i'll think later but i'll tell you if
he's
diving deep into the position he spent
nearly half his time on this one move
and
who might kick himself later because
three of the queen moves are fine
and i think the only move that would be
a mistake here bringing the black queen
across one square that's the least
natural of them anyway um you don't want
to put your queen opposite your
opponent's fricks
okay he needs to move i'll tell you how
magnus will be gaining in confidence the
longer
that he sees his opponent think
yeah
let's move that queen big question yeah
and i love this
wow and i love the fact that it's gonna
psychologically reveal the state of mind
you know if he's moves his queen all the
way back i mean that's a clever move but
it's also like scaredy cat yeah that's
the kind of move i would play and then
i'd be like oh no i'm scared just keep
me safe please i don't want to lose my
queen blunt my queen against magnus
and i guess he would be kind of
considering if he steps forward with the
queen one square then maybe you know
he'll be and okay and it's happened on
the board and i was wondering whether
maybe white now can strike in the center
because you know this is something that
magnus will always have in the pocket
you know the pawn will the the
the pawn in front of the queen will move
one square forward at any time so this
is something that artemia has to
calculate on every single turn is it
possible now
yeah um it's definitely possible now is
something that maybe magnus will
consider just to show your idea on the
board ivanka um
this black pawn is doing great it looks
like it's clamping down on the position
stopping white from advancing a pawn on
either of these two squares but
magnus will be trying to find the
opportune moment that small window uh
where he can push one of these pawns
forward and you're mentioning it now
ivanka i think this is quite a clever
move however there's a lot of tension on
this line and it's not clear who opening
the position up will favor so i think
now taking this pawn would probably be a
mistake for black because it would allow
the white knight forward attacking this
rook attacking a pawn and this white
knight amply protected by these two
pieces this would be real trouble now
for black but black can maybe ignore
this and
i mean i'm trying to find a useful move
it's not easy at all for black maybe i
can move this black knight out the way
but for example if i just play a random
pawn move white isn't yet threatening to
capture this pawn because there was a
pin on this line and now after queen
takes queen the rook recaptures black
would actually win a rook in the process
so
um if white does do this which i think
is the maybe one of the best moves but
definitely the most ambitious move then
it's maximum tension and it could go
either way very quickly
i think maybe black should maybe retreat
this knight just to open up this this
bishop
we mentioned white strong bishop on this
square black also has a nice bishop on a
long diagonal
but either way magnus is definitely
considering taking some action with one
of these pawn pushers most likely um if
he wants to play safe he could just
retreat his knight but stepping back
it's not his style it's not what anyone
really wants to do so is now the moment
will we see the world champion take a
risk and maybe push this pawn forward is
this one of those games where you say oh
joe is the least likely result or
whatever
anything can happen here you know
there's so much tension in the position
and uh whilst we're waiting for a reply
from magnus i do have to share with you
a few selfies
and uh we have louise who is watching
from ireland
and she is cheering for alexandra
kassanik and well we all wish alexandre
castanec the best of luck and uh oh well
magnus has advanced his another pawn and
now there's even more tension in the
position
and uh wow oh yeah the question is
thrown back to artemis what's he going
to do how is he going to handle that
because presumably it's the same idea
after pawn takes born that white knight
can
jump into that square yeah i think that
would be a huge mistake capturing that
white pawn it's poisoned he's actually
just offering up this pawn as bait
magnus carson it's a sacrifice but if
black accepts the sacrifice
bad things will happen the white knight
will jump forward to that magical c6
square that we highlighted a few moments
ago and black's pieces are just not
ready for that to happen so black needs
to avoid touching any of his pawns right
now i think he needs to move the knight
i'm not sure which square the black
knight wants to jump to but once the
black knight does move the black dark
square bishop will hit the white knight
in the middle of the board and maybe
cause magnus to at least have to react
have to take a step back and uh yeah i
think magnus is playing against the
clock situation from artemiev
he's taking risks now and uh yeah as you
mentioned kaya all three results are
possible a draw is far far away i doubt
that will uh that will see a draw in
this position but if we do it will be
after a lot of fighting
fighting chess and it's a critical
moment as you highlight and i'd also
have to show you a selfie from monroe al
you'll appreciate this one so he's
saying he's ready well they're ready to
go with their new mug which is one of
the i found the winning move max from
askgilt may the best player win
nice choice of mug very nice and well
congratulations on uh being one of the
winners of those puzzles nice yeah we
have lots of competitions throughout the
champions chess tour right we did last
season and we will again and yeah um we
had a countdown this year of puzzles
from last season so keep an eye on our
twitter yes for that um yeah i'm a bit
jealous so i wanted a face with oscars i
wanted a mug sorry with asking his face
on it
but uh no i didn't win unfortunately oh
well something else has me on social
media david is your new facebook page
yeah uh i do have a facebook page it has
it's so cool as well you like it yeah i
love it because you know now i can you
know i talk to you here and i want to
hang out with you as much as i can but
you know you're a busy man and you know
you're a popular guy you play
tournaments and you know but now i can
follow everything you do and you know
who you hang out with then behind the
scenes i love it yeah i'll be dropping
some serious selfies on there sometime
behind the scenes action um some news we
have a new podcast coming out as well
we'll talk about that a bit later
so yeah go check out that facebook page
definitely and yeah we're going to talk
about that podcast as well a new podcast
is launching today you guys with oscar
and uh david and a mystery guest we will
review later on
and meanwhile some action on the board i
did mention black's knight probably
wanted to jump out the way just to open
up the black dark square bishop and that
did happen black's knight retreated we
saw white capture a knight and now
actually both the dart squad bishops
have been traded off they have
disappeared from the board and this i
quite like it from artemis side he
simplified the position
then again
it feels like magnus maybe has a small
advantage um just because of the fact he
will have an extra central pawn a bit
later on maybe now for example magnus
can initiate even more trades take off
one of the black pawns open up a line
for his rook
and
yeah it feels like black maybe
temporarily at least on the back foot
yeah still roughly balanced but what do
you think of whose position do you
prefer you know
i'm gonna
answer your question in two parts parts
um when it comes to the position i think
black is okay
when i look at the clock situation i'm
like oh
you know magnus has got just over five
minutes and artemia f is just under
three minutes when i look at that i
think it's the in magnus's uh advantage
if you were to maintain the tension on
the board a little bit longer so rather
than trade i would be like ah
let's build a little bit yeah just make
i'll tell you sweat make him work for
the exactly changes for the truth
exactly and make him just think about
you know calculate the possibility of
white trading that pawn on every single
move
and uh well one thing we do know about
artemis though is that you having said
all that about the clock situation is
that artemia is a fantastic calculator
he calculates so quickly and he's in his
element in simple positions we've seen
him find the most fantastic combinations
with seconds to spare on the clock
but
but you know people are in in situations
of chaos yeah and it might not look like
a huge difference on the clock but it
will become a factor for sure um as i
mentioned actually i played darth vader
a few months ago i was playing for
england he was playing for russia at the
european team championship and
every move i was thinking okay i can't
give him an end game i can't give him a
simple position he will trick me he will
outplay me um so i was lucky just having
watched lots of his games on the tour
that i learned a bit about his style but
magnus is actually going against that
advice he did trade off some pawns he
did trade off one set of rooks now we
mentioned white's rook has found an open
line white's rook on that c file is
fantastic but it might get traded off at
some point by black blacks rook even now
could just sidestep one square trade off
those rooks and suddenly artemiev he's
in a position where he thrives
all of the danger is gone white doesn't
have any material left to go on an
attack against the black king no real
checkmating ideas
white just pushing harry the h pawn
there trying to maybe push it forward
even further but
black can block the push of that pawn
black and trade rooks it feels like
artemiev is guiding this game towards
safety
kenny guided longer than that to you
know winning situations yeah there's
some danger actually for magnus you know
if things really go wrong for him you
know take a look at the pawn structure
now take a look at which pawns are
passed which ones that don't have an
opponent and you look that artemiev has
a poor majority on the left side of the
board
and that means that in a king and pawn
ending he would have
almost a winning advantage yep if the
queen's come off actually then i think
black is the only one who can win
because of that two versus one uh
majority over there as you mentioned uh
ivanka so i think magnus really needs to
keep the queens on because he needs to
be active he's now pushing in the center
but white central pawns take an age to
push forward and to break through uh to
create a past pawn black's pawns
especially if the queens come off will
just easily run down the board they'll
sprint towards that angle um so as you
vancouver mentioned now white doesn't
really want to trade bishops what
doesn't really want to trade queens and
that means there's not actually that
much margin for error
maybe trading the queens at some point
will be okay but he needs to make sure
those black pawns aren't running
and uh yeah right now who would you
prefer i've said white about four or
five moves ago i would change my mind
now
and say black
um i i think black has has the upper
hand here i agree with you and magnus
actually following the rule book the
rule book says that when you have a past
pawn you should push him
and he's doing that very elementary yeah
where on whichever side you have the
majority that's where you try and
initiate the play and white does have
this kind of five versus four on this in
the center and on the right so he's
trying to push uh much push now but this
move actually for me
breaks a few of the rules you know
because you know i know it's an end game
and there isn't much danger to the black
king but still suddenly take a look at
that diagonal the king is feeling a
little bit nervous especially because
he's the queen and bishop that can
potentially attack on the like light
squares which is just weakened yeah so
also we just mentioned you should push
on the side that you're stronger yeah
black there has pushed on the side that
he's weaker where he has fewer pawns so
you're right king safety it might look
like an end game but while queen's
remain king safety is still paramount
it's still very important
and magnus
what's he considering i would be very
tempted to actually push forward the
white central pawn to attack the black
queen so white's pawn on the e file push
it forward one square attack that black
queen also white bishop a bit blocked in
by its central pawn there so if you push
that pawn you open up the bishop's scope
it's still not much uh i'm surprised to
see the evaluation bar go over to
whiteside that much
uh but yeah maybe a slightly careless
move by artemia
favorite pawn structure yeah on the ball
he's not holding back yeah three pawns
all sitting in the same row wow
that's ambitious i'm very surprised
because i just talked about king safety
and now white's king is not entirely
safe anymore but
i like the idea behind it white just
wants to throw everything forward in the
center and uh yeah maybe again that's
with one eye on our 10 minutes clock
suddenly black is going to be on the
defensive once those pawns continue
rushing forward
and one minute left now for artemiev
yeah i mean he's super quick he
calculates very very uh speedily but
magnus in these types of situations is
ruthless so
okay 0.0 according to the computer but
still a draw is far away still a lot of
life left that's that move uh pushing
those that pawn
two squares forward is kind of like a
hustle hustling move you know you go
into hustle mode because you start to
threaten
you don't actually threaten anything
but you kind of you hint you hint at
ideas and you start putting those ghosts
in the position and there we see it we
see our tamiya has reacted to the threat
and he's pushed his pawn in the center i
mean
that is
wow i'm surprised by that because it's
allowed magnus the best type of pawn you
can possibly get which is a protected
past pawn okay that pawn is going to
push itself forward yeah there's two
options though because there's a this is
a poor sacrifice
as well i'll tell you if could just uh
carlton now could just grab this black
central pawn and it's protected by
white's queen white's queen on the
diagonal will guard white central pawn
there however maybe the reason you're
not so keen on that move is because
white's pawns then would be isolated and
doubled
and maybe having two double pawns is not
necessarily better than having um one
strong past porn yeah you're right your
instincts were correct they're your
anchor but uh it's always nice to have
that like like little joker card in your
pocket and that's what a protective pass
pawn is because once again if you fast
forward to a king and pawn ending that
pawn is going to win the game yeah if
the bishops and queens disappear now
then white is the one winning right and
that was i mean it was pretty much the
opposite just three or four moves ago so
magnus has definitely gained something
over the last few turns and now okay
black's pawn's done to much forward and
white taking a timeout to shuffle the
king to the corner to safety it wasn't
maybe it's also got the hidden plan i
don't know whether there's any good
trend of bishops
yeah make those trades and kind of just
say hey
you know remember that pawn i got in the
center of the board but i still got it
yeah and i'm gonna make use of it yeah
so white's bishop now could actually
step one square in front of the white
king the white king now protecting that
square and that would offer a trade of
bishops big moment does artemev continue
i think he has to just in practical
terms he has to continue pushing those
pawns in ivanka yeah both sides now uh
playing their main ideas black pushing
his pawns forward on the side he's
stronger on this side of the board white
now trying to trade bishops once the
bishops disappear as they have done now
white queen is gonna try and snake her
way in uh to the black position she's
gonna offer a trade of queens maybe try
to start checking the black king and
yeah that's an open line she's about to
enter the black position and she's and
magnus is following the golden rule that
you've said told us in queen upon
endings which is always activate your
queen maximize her potential okay i'll
tell you have given a check he doesn't
have much time on the clock and now the
white king starts finding a safe place
on the second row yeah and again the
engine the computer might say 0.0 but
this is a difficult position to defend
black is on the defensive i'm pretty
sure and he's only got 20 seconds left
less than 20 seconds now
so yeah this one we might see the
evaluation really shoot up in the space
of one or two moves i think black has to
activate his king now because okay there
we go the black king was doing nothing
not contributing
um white central pawn that the white d5
pawn the past pawn is going to start
marching at some point so the black king
has to move towards it
but the computer has shot up suddenly um
what could white's idea be feels like
white has to activate the queen now
can you quite jump in with the queen
start attacking some of black's pawns
i think you can i think you could you
can mark you put her on the fifth row i
i think because the main thing that
white has to calculate is whether the
black queen can activate herself and
start posing a threat to the white king
but i think it's not a problem i'm
pretty sure it's not a problem because
white's queen is so powerful i mean if
it is a problem then you find a safe
place for your king and that's it okay
so magnus is given a check so we were
maybe advocating this move the white
queen hitting some pawns and uh as you
mentioned ivanka potentially uh magnus
was scared of the black queen jumping
forward this way uh to try and sneak in
towards the king or maybe even this way
but instead magnus has given a check and
uh now the black king has had to run
away magnus now um what's he planning
maybe he's going to jump into the
position with his queen maybe the black
king just not on a great square now it's
in a dark square it might get checked
okay magnus actually chooses the square
we mentioned but he's worsened the
position of the black king first so now
if the black queen does jump forward
white does have a nasty nasty check
hitting the king and next move gobbling
up a black pawn and i'm taking a look at
the clock situation here on my computer
and i can see seconds remaining and okay
yeah no i think it's a mistake from
artemis because now magnus has this
check that we mentioned he's played it
the black king has run and it's a double
attack and now magnus okay he's he's
winning all he needs to do let's go back
to the place he needs to bring his queen
back swap the queens and then this pawn
will match up and win let's go back to
the players is magnus gonna find the
winning move bringing his queen back and
trading off the black queen
ivanka does that just win on the spot it
wins on the spot and it's on the board
he's found it and look at this it's a
pawn race but white pawns are gonna be
just
one move quicker
and uh there we go white's gonna
continue pushing that pawn in the center
i think the queens there's tension there
but it's as if they don't exist so the
queens have traded i think the black
king is might even get checkmated i hope
we see checkmate on the board
is about to allow this two queens and
then magnus will deliver checkmate
oh no he's going to resign is he before
checkmate no allows the tech mate show
us the checkmate vladislav ah
well
what a start though for magnus carlsen
in the military championship 2022 what a
win and what a game what a game it
really heated up at the end there yeah
and we said it the computer said 0.0 but
if you have less than one minute left in